you know question answering in general
is the field of artificial intelligence
or natural language processing where the
computer is expected to give a precise
answer to a question that's given in
natural language Watson is is a software
system which means that it has a variety
of different programs that are all
working together to try and get the
right answer but it's also a hardware
system so it's a big distributed
computing system that has lots of
processing cores
so the typical computer that a consumer
might have on their desktop might have
two cores or four cores and it CPUs or
central processing units I think Watson
now has over 2,000 of those the way that
Watson works is to break down a clue in
in the Jeopardy game and then
immediately attempt to generate all
possible answer candidates that it
thinks might answer the question my job
was to estimate how likely each answer
candidate is given supporting evidence
and the challenge was that there are so
many different ways to express same
concept in human language you can say
professor Nyberg teaches at Carnegie
Mellon or dr. eggnog is a faculty member
a Carnegie Mellon
you know there means ways to express a
similar idea so solving ambiguity is a
big challenge that we face in natural
language processing in general in the
watson project as well for example when
a computer sees bank it doesn't know
whether it's a financial bank or river
bank so i've been working on the source
part of question answering system so the
ideas to collect and grow the right kind
of source content that you may need
we'll find answers to questions and also
to find evidence that supports those
answers one tough challenge is that it's
an open domain question answering
program this means that the questions
can be pretty much about anything so
this requires the system to store all
sorts of information that may possibly
be relevant and then process this
information in real time all the QA
systems that had been built up until
Watson
you know answered in less than a minute
if they were really good so a question
answering wasn't ready for primetime in
terms of real time business applications
because it was slow another area that
was very important for Watson is what we
call confidence processing in the
Jeopardy game there's a big penalty if
you give a wrong answer and it's much
better to remain silent
if you don't think you have the right
answer the only way for a computer to do
that is to have a model of its own
confidence in its answers and QA systems
didn't really have a model of confidence
before Watson came along and I think the
third big challenge is the fact that the
Jeopardy language is very tricky it's
very creative it plays on all of our
human abilities to understand language
in all the different you know forms that
it's used this Japanese change does not
trust in both traditional question
hunting but it also involves strategy so
basically you're playing a game against
human contestants and actually you have
to adapt to the behavior of your
opponents and also their success so for
example if your opponents start making a
lot of money and they array ahead of you
then you may be willing to take more
risk and then at this point key
Watson system may actually decide to
answer questions even if it has pretty
low confidence or on the other hand if
it's by the head of the other players it
may try to play safe and only busts in
if it's actually really certain about
the answer the thing about Watson once
you watch it play several games against
humans is that you'll notice very
quickly that it makes mistakes that
humans wouldn't make it's going to give
some answers in the final match that
you know have people laughing okay on
the other hand it gives answers that you
and I would never be able to give unless
we were like the world's expert in you
know Italian opera or you know obscure
films or whatever because that had
access you know to lots and lots of
information in real time so I think for
me the best outcome of the final match
would be one where sort of Watson's
strengths are showcased but also its
weaknesses are evident so that no one
sort of believes that it's more
intelligent or more powerful than it
really is still lots of work to be done
you know to make it as you know smart as
we are after this everyone will know
what question-answering is and I think
that's actually the number one benefit
for us is that it's going to focus on
what question-answering can do for you
beyond search and it's also I think
going to generate a lot of interest and
applications of that technology that can
immediately you know sort of have impact
in the real world